[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert könig für den sport
und das sind die themen von heute
deutschland schwitzt vor allem älteren
machen die extremen temperaturen zu
schaffen und in brandenburg kämpfte die
feuerwehr gegen die hitze folgen
neue doppelspitze bei der afg kino
kubala wird mit knapper mehrheit erneut
zum parteichef gewählt co-vorsitzende
wird alice weil
und deutliche kritik bei dokumente
eröffnung bundespräsident steinmeier
beklagte unter anderem dass keine
künstler und künstlerinnen aus israel
eingeladen sind
zum glück ist heute samstag und die
meisten haben ohnehin frei hitzefrei der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt für das
gesamte wochenende vor extremen
temperaturen ein vorgeschmack auf die
zukunft sagen klimaforscher
die wetterkarte zeigt ein geteiltes
deutschland im norden sehr angenehme
temperaturen der rest des landes die
große hitze vor allem zwischen oberrhein
und ostbrandenburg hier zeigen die
zeigten die thermometer bis zu 37 grad
über dem bisher heißesten tag des jahres
sandra susanka
einfach nur abkühlen diesen wunsch
hatten viele heute in deutschland nicht
nur wie hier in stuttgart die freibäder
übervoll die uv werte hoch hitzewarnung
fast bundesweit 36 grad in stuttgart vor
allem in den städten ist die heiße
nordafrikanische luft die seit heute bei
uns angekommen ist kaum auszuhalten wir
bewegen uns ganz langsam und wir suchen
schattige plätze und wir trinken viel
aber schattige plätze sind selten also
wir quetschen uns hier schon auf die
auch die bank ich dachte sogar es wird
noch unerträglicher also vom kreislauf
vermerk schon heute aber noch nicht so
wie ich dachte aber zeigt ja auch dass
sich wahrscheinlich die welt verändert
vom klima her dass es jetzt schon so
früh so hanisch brütende hitze die sogar
die statik eines hauses gefährdet ein
düsseldorfer mehrfamilienhaus musste
evakuiert werden weil sich ein
stahlträger stark ausgedehnt hatte risse
im mauerwerk waren die folge besonders
menschen wie dachdeckermeister mai kühne
aus dessau der auch am wochenende
arbeitet macht die extreme hitze zu
schaffen
68 70 grad sag ich mal dann drückt von
unten die wärme durch flammen und dann
halt von oben die sonne das dann
natürlich immer so
belastungsgrenze sage ich jetzt mal für
den körper ist es momentan schwierig
sich auf die wechselnden temperaturen
einzustellen man sollte deshalb auf
signale achten voran der kreislauf gibt
danach man fühlt sich schwindlig etwas
benommen etwas unwohl manchmal auch sehr
unspezifisch und man sollte eben
deswegen darauf achten dass man genügend
und das ist manchmal schwierig genau zu
wissen wie viel das ist flüssigkeit zu
sich und in schleswig holstein am
timmendorfer strand genießen die
menschen bei angenehmeren temperaturen
um die 28 grad den ersten hitzetag an
der ostsee bei einem lauen lüftchen
konnte man es dort heute gut aushalten
wir werden uns wenn wir den klimawandel
nicht gegensteuern an wetter extreme
gewinnen müssen die hitze gepaart mit
der trockenheit hat längst auch in
deutschland deutliche folgen wasser wird
immer knapper die gefahr von waldbränden
immer größer was das zum beispiel in
brandenburg aktuell bedeutet zeigt
katrin lindner
waldbrand in front dorf südlich von
berlin löschen geht nur aus der distanz
im boden laut munition aus zwei
weltkriegen 40 hektar wald stehen noch
in flammen bereits rund 220 waldbrände
in diesem jahr zählt brandenburg
landesweit haben wir heute die höchste
waldbrandgefahrenstufe fünf ausgerufen
das heißt in jedem landkreis diese
gefahr die spree bei cottbus wichtig für
die wasserversorgung von berlin schon
jetzt braucht der fluss zusätzliches
wasser aus talsperren und die stadt
cottbus hat die entnahme von wasser aus
flüssen und seen tagsüber zum beispiel
für den kleingarten untersagt im letzten
jahr war es dann glaube ich schon ende
juli erst als das passierte aber nun
hatten wir ja am anfang schon gleich
beizeiten einen sehr trockenen frühling
und wir haben insgesamt in der region
grundwasserstände die sind bis zu 80 cm
und dann unter dem früheren
grundwasserständen der cottbuser ostsee
nördlich der stadt soll einmal der
größte künstliche see deutschlands
werden die flutung gestoppt erst im
herbst kann es weitergehen wenn
hoffentlich mehr wasser da ist doch
darauf kann sich heute keiner mehr
verlassen ein stück weit ist der trend
den man jetzt über die letzten
jahrzehnte beobachtet durchaus
stärker als es uns auch klimamodelle für
den gleichen zeitraum projizieren und
das bedeutet dass die reale welt
durchaus extremer ist wer in diesen
tagen in brandenburg unterwegs ist spürt
schon jetzt deutlich die härte des
klimawandels und
der krieg macht klimaschutz noch
schwerer weil russland immer weniger gas
liefert muss sich deutschland
alternativen überlegen gas einsparen zum
beispiel bei der stromerzeugung
aktuell stammen
31,5 prozent des in deutschland
erzeugten und eingespeisten stroms aus
kohle dicht gefolgt
windkraft mit gut 30 prozent 13 stammt
aus erdgas der gasanteil soll weiter
runter sagen jetzt viele und setzen
trotz der klimaschädlichkeit auf noch
mehr kohle daniel konnten mehr davon
will die industrie sofort
kohlekraftwerke aus der reserve holen
und schon jetzt die gasverstromung
stoppen fordert der bundesverband bdi
wenn die versorgungslage im sommer sich
tatsächlich so schwierig entwickelt wie
es aktuell wahrgenommen wird müssen wir
diese option jetzt sofort ziehen so
siegfried russwurm der import von strom
aus nachbarländern habe seine grenzen
unterstützung dafür gibt es aus cdu/csu
nicht dagegen für den vorschlag des
bundeswirtschaftsministers
heiztemperatur in den wohnungen
abzusenken notfalls per gesetz ich habe
dieser tage nicht den eindruck dass viel
geheizt wird in den wohnungen und bevor
er habe den bürgerinnen und bürgern
vorschlägt zufrieren finde ich sollte
erst mal tun was der staat regeln kann
mehr kohlekraftwerke nutzen um gas zu
sparen für den winter von greenpeace
heißt es achtsames heizen könne helfen
vor allem aber müsse auch die industrie
von der politik zum einsparen von gas
gedrängt werden durch bessere isolierung
etwa und mehr wärme pumpen wie schnell
änderungen wirksam werden können ist
fraglich zumal es auch innerhalb der
ampel koalition noch abstimmungsbedarf
gibt
energiesparen ist eine gute idee ob man
das am ende gesetzlich verankern sollte
dann mache ich erstmal ein fragezeichen
run wichtig ist dass wir gut durch den
winter kommen und als staat alles dafür
tun dass die energiesicherheit in
deutschland gewährleistet ist in diesem
ziel ist man sich einig die frage bleibt
der weg je mehr russland seine
gaslieferungen drosselt desto höher wird
der entscheidungsdruck
ein ausführliches interview mit dem chef
des bundesverbands der deutschen
industrie sehen sie morgen in berlin
direkt direkt nach uns um 19 uhr 10
ost und west mann und frau handwerker
und akademikerinnen kino copala und
alice weidl führen nicht mehr nur die
fdp-fraktion im bundestag sondern jetzt
auch die partei das duo wurde auf dem
parteitag in riesa zur neuen
doppelspitze gewählt allerdings war die
sympathie der delegierten sehr ungleich
verteilt christiane hübsche hat mir
die afg gibt timo grub aller noch eine
chance er ist der neue alte vorsitzende
wenn auch nur mit schlappen 53 prozent
wiedergewählt alois seidl wird neue co
vorsitzende zusammen sollen sie die
partei wieder aufrichten heute beginnt
der aufbruch ich schaue nicht mehr
zurück was gewesen ist was war die ära
leuten ist mit dem heutigen tag beendet
gegenkandidaten norbert kleinwächter
versucht für den sogenannten gemäßigten
flügel ein anderes angebot müssen aus
dem tief indem wir sind dringend raus
kommen mit einer neuen politischen
kommunikation mit einem neuen stil mit
einem neuen wind dass die wähler da
draußen auch sehen ahadi afd da tut sich
was positives erschafft einen echten
achtungserfolg mehr aber nicht alice
will bekommt mit 67 prozent mehr
zustimmung als cro pallasch wird die von
weiten geschwächte afd auf einigkeit und
disziplin ein wer von uns hat denn
wirklich gedacht dass es bei einem
projekt wie der asd keine zwischen
schläge geben würde es war völlig klar
das imperium schlägt zurück und darauf
werden wir reagieren
eine doppelspitze von björn büchs gnaden
der bekannte rechtsextremist und
thüringer landeschef zieht hier in riesa
ganz offen die fäden unterstützt auch
die weiteren bisher gewählten mitglieder
der parteiführung
dieser neue bundesvorstand entspricht
bisher vollständig meinem geschmack ich
bin vorsichtig optimistisch dass es uns
gelingt ja parteifreundin dieses amt zu
bekommen in die ämter zu bekommen die
auch die charakter größe haben und die
festigkeit haben zu kooperieren andere
müssen dafür platz machen die afg
führung rückt mit diesem parteitag heute
weiter nach rechts
nicole diekmann ist für uns in riesa was
ist von dieser neuen parteiführung zu
erwarten
das ist schon eine bemerkenswerte
schieflage teleskop aller der es gerade
so geschafft hat wiedergewählt zu werden
und schwer angeschlagen ist und auf der
anderen seite alice weidl die jetzt neu
im amt ist und ein viel besseres
ergebnis erzielt hat das bibb
konfliktpotenzial und das ausgerechnet
zwischen den beiden die die zerstrittene
und durch eine serie von wahlschlappen
geschwächte afd eigentlich jetzt ein
sollen hoppala und beide haben
allerdings auch viel gemeinsam so haben
sie zum beispiel hier in riesa auch
damit für sich geworben die recht
draußen stärker einbinden zu wollen und
sie leugnen beide rechtsextremisten in
der partei zu haben das bezweifelt der
bundesverfassungsschutz ja bekanntlich
und beobachtet die gesamte afg seit
wenigen monaten als
rechtsextremistischen verdachtsfall den
thüringischen landeschef jan hoet stuft
er als gesicherten rechtsextremisten 1
und eben dieser höcker hat die
zusammensetzung des neuen
bundesvorstands dessen letzte wahl
runden hinter mir gerade noch laufen
maßgeblich orchestriert die rechtsaußen
in der afg demonstrieren hier auf diesem
parteitag sehr eindrücklich ihre macht
und die selbsternannten gemäßigten haben
keine chance die einschätzung unserer
korrespondentin nicole diekmann vielen
dank
justizminister buschmann hat sich
skeptisch zur wiedereinführung der
masken pflicht geäußert wenn die korona
infektionen weiter stark steigen
offenbar hält er ihren nutzen für
wissenschaftlich nicht eindeutig
erwiesen er wolle die ergebnisse des
sachverständigenrats abwarten sagte
buschmann der rheinischen post prompt
die kritik vom weltärztebund die
wissenschaftliche evidenz zum sinn von
masken pflicht sei erdrückend sagt
präsident montgomery der funke
mediengruppe
zum krieg tag 114 mehrere städte im
osten der ukraine sind weiter schwer
umkämpft nach ukrainischen angaben
versuchen russische truppen unter
anderem sei wie aero donetsk
einzukesseln währenddessen besuchte
präsident sie lenski die frontstadt
nicolai im süden des landes nach
heftigen kämpfen wieder
sollten dort gelungen die russischen
truppen zurückzudrängen
fast elf jahre ist es jetzt her das
massaker auf der norwegischen insel
utoya an die opfer erinnert jetzt ein
mahnmal drei meter hohe säulen 77 eine
für jedes der überwiegend jungen
todesopfer zusammen mit prinz haakon
weiten hinterbliebene und überlebende
auf utoya die gedenkstätte ein der
rechtsextremist breivik hatte 69
teilnehmer eines politischen sommercamps
erschossen und zuvor in oslo acht
menschen mit einer bombe getötet
für den nächsten 100 tage schaut die
kunstwelt auf kassel heute begann die
dokumente eine der bedeutendsten
ausstellungen für moderne kunst die nur
alle fünf jahre stattfindet dieses jahr
liegt der fokus auf dem globalen süden
den ärmeren regionen der welt zur
eröffnung gab es auch kritische worte
vom bundespräsidenten mehr von reisen
eigentlich soll es ja um kunst gehen
wenn der bundespräsident die documenta
besucht doch nach dem betrachten einiger
werke gibt steinmeier scharfe kritik an
den machern der ausstellung so
unsensibel seit deren umgang mit dem
thema antisemitismus dass er überlegt
habe gar nicht zu kommen
die freiheit der meinung und die
freiheit der kunst in wesens kern
unserer verfassung kritik an israel ist
erlaubt doch wo kritik an israel
umschlägt in die infragestellung seiner
existenz da ist eben die grenze
überschritten einen boykott israels
kommt eben eine existenz verweigerung
bleibt das kuratorium ein indonesisches
künstlerkollektiv hatten
palästinensische künstler eingeladen
aber keine israelischen die bilderreihe
guernica gaza auf der documenta setzt
sich mit israels vorgehen in den
palästinenser-gebieten kritisch
auseinander das kuratorium wie auch die
dokumente leitung distanzieren sich aber
klar von antisemitismus
neben die deutsche verantwortung sehr
ernst und beschäftigen uns auch damit
auch die künstlerinnen und künstler
haben sich hier sehr eng damit
auseinandergesetzt nur der gesamte
ansatz dieser documenta ist ja in die
zukunft gerichtet und deswegen ist diese
eindeutige beschäftigung mit der
deutschen vergangenheit an dieser stelle
einfach nicht das thema gewesen ein
großes thema der documenta die
perspektive des globalen südens
es ist das erste mal dass ich erlebe
dass es eigentlich überhaupt keine
grenze zwischen dem besucher und der
ausstellung gibt dass man dann alles
eintauchen kann ich habe mich so in die
80er versetzt gefühlt wo wir
gemeinwesenarbeit gemacht haben wir
haben nicht so viel daran erinnert jetzt
bin ich gespannt wie es weiter geht 100
tage lang ist kassel nun der nabel der
kunstwelt
endlich nach zwei jahren chor ohne
einschränkungen gibt es die kieler woche
wieder in alter form und größe ein
volksfest für die kehle und ihre gäste
millionen menschen werden an neun tagen
zu segelregatta windjammerparade und
unter meile erwartet zum comeback gab es
hier im norden auch das perfekte wetter
über 30 grad dagegen beim tennisturnier
in halle westfalen das für oscar oder
jetzt leider auch vorbei ist aber hat
seinen gegner nicht leicht gemacht mich
absolut und in der form vermutet man
wird er auch in wimbledon den einen oder
anderen top star ärgern können gegen den
weltranglisten-ersten verloren aber viel
selbstvertrauen getankt erst im
halbfinale muss aus karotte dem gegner
gratulieren
daniel medwedew war in den
entscheidenden momenten besser
die sensation bleibt aus doch lange kann
sich aus karotte auf augenhöhe mit der
nummer eins zeigen immer wieder
begeistert der kölner die 11.000
zuschauer mit spektakulären ballwechseln
wie diesen selbstbewusst
reich sein spiel erst im tie break nach
über einer stunde holt sich da nie mit
wef den ersten satz
im zweiten gelingen dem russischen
weltranglisten ersten die wichtigen
punkte mit madoff gewinnt 7 zu 6 und 6 3
schade ich hätte gern im finale gespielt
aber auf einer liste anerkennung auch
vom gegner für eine erfolgreiche woche
aus karotte besiegte bei seiner ersten
teilnahme in halle 3 besser platzierte
spieler und kann nun voller zuversicht
nach wimbledon reisen
leonie elbert ist fecht europameisterin
die florett spezialisten vom team future
fencing werbach gewinnt in antalya das
finale gegen die italienerin arianna
errigo mit 15 12 treffern team kollegin
anne sauer wird fünfter zum auftakt der
schwimm-weltmeisterschaften in rom schon
die erste medaille für deutschland lukas
mertens vom sc magdeburg gewinnt silber
über 400 meter freistil als
weltjahresbester über die drei langen
freistilstrecken geht mertens in sein
erstes wm-finale am schluss muss der
20-jährige nur dem australier ringt um
1,63 sekunden den vortritt lassen
merkens wer medaille ist die erste für
deutschland auf dieser strecke seit 11
und bei den para
schwimm-weltmeisterschaften auf madeira
krönt tanja schulz ihre erfolgreiche
vorstellung mit medaillen nummer fünf
scholz seit einem reitunfall vor zwei
jahren querschnittsgelähmt holt sich
über 200 meter freistil der klasse s 4
ihren dritten titel bei dieser wm für
die fans haanerin nach 2 53 02 der
goldene abschluss eines traumhaften
der fc bayern münchen bleibt im rennen
um die deutsche basketball meisterschaft
durch einen unerwartet klaren sieg im
dritten spiel des playoff finales bei
alba berlin
überraschung von
14.500 zuschauern beenden die
ersatzgeschwächten münchner in rot auf
beeindruckende weise die berliner serie
von zuletzt 19 spielen ohne niederlage
19 teils spektakuläre punkte von
topscorer nick weilerbach helfen bei 90
zu 60 auswärtssieg morgen spiel 4 in
münchen zweiter matchball für berlin
das was dankeschön wir feiern jetzt noch
einen superstar für viele ist er der
mozart des zwanzigsten jahrhundert und
wird heute kaum zu glauben 80 jahre alt
paul mccartney seine stimme ist etwas
rauer geworden seine musik aber ist
alterslos mit den beatles schrieb er
musikgeschichte
prägte eine ganze generation
[Musik]
noch heute geht er auf tour als legen
die anfänge der berühmten pilzköpfe nur
wenige jahre zurück und nicht mehr als
ein halbes jahrhundert
[Musik]
wie es mit der hitze weiter geht und wo
morgen gewitter zu erwarten sind das
erzählt uns gleich katja hornuf
christian sievers begrüßt sie im heute
journal um viertel vor elf wir danken
für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen noch
einen schönen abend und freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder dabei sind auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
es ist ja nicht so dass es heute in ganz
deutschland richtig heiß war denn im
norden machte sich schon diese kleine
kaltfront bemerkbar so lagen die
temperaturen auf sylt nur über 18 grad
36 grad wurden es dagegen in jena 37
grad in bad kreuznach und dieses gefälle
macht sich auch in der nacht bemerkbar
im norden sinken die werte auf 14 bis 11
grad tropisch bleibt die nacht zwischen
west sachsen und dem saarland da sinken
die werte nicht unter 20 grad meist ist
es klar und diese kleine kaltfront
bringt im norden etwas regen es kann
auch mal ein gewitter dabei sein morgen
vormittag lässt der regen da erstmal
nach und etwa südlich vom sauerland harz
und berlin ist es einfach nur sehr
sonnig nachmittags intensiviert sich
dann der regen und dann kann es in den
mittelgebirgen und auch aus den alpen
heraus zum abendmahl gewitter geben die
können auch mal heftiger ausfallen wenn
sie berlin verlassen um die wärme an der
ostsee zu genießen dann werden sie dort
gar nicht finden denn genau wie an der
nordsee bleibt es da kühl mit 16 17 grad
bis auf 39 grad können die temperaturen
dagegen hier im östlichen sachsen oder
auch am oberrhein steigen und die neue
woche startet sommerlich aber längst
nicht mehr so haß am sonntag